hey dear can Charlotte North Carolina
was upcam from Charlotte and this uh
Cheryl does a woman's name - it's also a
city so you know what I'm saying
sometimes if you see a dude just humping
the air in the middle of town he say
dang what's going on boy he say oh I'm
just getting a little bit of Charlotte
you feel me going good
20 years old young buck trying to figure
out my way in life 20 years old right
there double decades right here onward
brother I got problem with these sweaty
hands man my dad I problems with it
doesn't not too worried about it but
comes a problem date oh you got them
sweaty hands huh
you got them leaky mitts baby tell me
more just wondering some advice that
maybe you give a young guy sweaty hands
oh you got that drip shake huh hmm I can
only imagine me you try to shake
somebody's hand you and your daddy
probably can't even handshake because
it's just like uh just like - like two
fists trying to uh
just like two fists trying to hug and
they can't it's like hmm
damn home word thank you if you give me
a little advice on what to do with these
headers thanks man
you got them leaky hitters Romney the
only thing you can do marry a plumber
you notice the old joke if you got
sweaty hands you marry a plumber but
damn boy you got them sweaty hands
that's trouble hmm
yeah that's a tough one man because I
mean you could keep like I don't know if
you ever been at the gymnasium but they
have this little thing of chalk
sometimes I guess people die they are a
lot or whatever and they'll put it on
their hands or something or um you know
if they're doing uh you know I guess I
don't know I don't know what it's for
really but people put it on their hands
there and you can do it too so you can
put one of those in the vehicle or
something what else you could hold the
hand hold your hands out of the window
when you drive so you know you can hold
your hands right out of the car window
when you drive like a little love like a
little bee Shawn and they do that
sometimes and hang your tongue out or
something - kind of cool them back then
bad boys off because those are that's
those [ __ ] front grippers baby them
hands you got a pair of them and I mean
yeah I don't know what else you could do
do get some gloves or something get some
cinnamon put it you know or do something
like seasonal samaa Oregon not a work on
a little bit of ging or you feel me that
ganger get you some of those game you
know or crumble up some gangers snaps or
whatever and put them on the front get
you right but you need some type of a
dust to cover it now that there's a
surgery you can get you got to get the
gland saw it out of your hands so I
don't know where you want to do that at
but but I would say I think it's a lot
of girls will think it's cute to you
know just tell them that make you
nervous or something I think now that's
a good way in the beginning say oh yeah
you know hey violet you know you really
making me nervous you know my hands are
really just leaking for you or get you
some special gloves some gloves that
match like your pants like Brendan
Schaub is like a guy that will wear some
[ __ ] weird gloves so do some [ __ ]
like that and do something but I think
if a girl said man your hands are real
wet
I would say look well look hey I'll get
wet if you get one in family now that's
kind of perverse but that's you know
that's not a real Christian way to go
about it but that's something you could
do and what else
mmm man the truth is somebody's gonna
love your damn wet hands they probably
got a lady out there sitting around with
dry ashy hands you know some lady she
just she's just leaving just real
intense fingerprints everywhere she goes
and people say damn I mean you probably
can't play solitaire cuz the cards get
all kind of law water logged up you know
they get off you know they swallow a
little but but they got some dry dry
lady out there I mean look at this you
mutt your father made you eat you know
he got them drippy mitts so it's all
we've all got something bro you know I
feel like I've been losing my hair dude
that's scary you know I got a big nose
right on the front of my face dude you
know much easier would be if my nose was
on the back of my face way easier but
you know we've all got some kind of
thing you know I got those [ __ ]
people don't want to talk about them a
lot those claves I got those up top
hitters baby them high ribs and them
[ __ ] are beautiful but you don't see
those a lot you know so we all have
things about ourselves that we don't
really enjoy so I think if you got some
you know just tell them you've been
doing laundry or something you could do
that but the unique thing about it is is
there's somebody else out there that's
got it just like you your father and you
have somebody to talk about it with and
if anything it's a gift man what if you
and your father had nothing in common
you know I'd give anything for to have
something you know to be able to talk to
my father and not only talk to him but
about something we had in common blame
him
you also have somebody to blame these
day you could take your daddy to court
sue em boy the state versus drip drop
you feel me but I think it's something
you have in common with your father
and he cares about you you know he's
damp with affection for his son he's
damp with sentiment for his boy and that
could be anything coming out of your
hands dude okay you know who knows man
damn that could be that body skeet but
it could be the Lord trying to just just
really blossom right out of your palms
so there's a lot going on with you man
and I think they're supposed to be you
know you don't want to have a dry
existence so I would put some you know
do maybe there's like a powder that's
real fine people wouldn't notice you
could put in your pockets you could wear
gloves really cool chill gloves or
something
fashions gotten so weird you could
almost do whatever you want you could do
some blue jean gloves or something like
that's something that's really kind of
unique or like rocky rocky number you
wore that and he just had a lisp so he
didn't even he wasn't even a fashionable
he has speech impediment he [ __ ] you
know wore mittens so Jesus Christ Brian
he had a great career but I think
there's a lot of possibility for you man
and I love you Brian I hope when I see
you dude you [ __ ] shake me you shake
my hand with one of those wet [ __ ]
baby cuz I'm gonna grip that thing and
I'm gonna pull you Lynn daddy and give
you that one-handed [ __ ] that [ __ ]
lava lock baby that love that [ __ ]
one-handed [ __ ] love hustle real fast
boy got half a hug you feel me I'm in
and out huh okay thank you guys for
checking out this clip and if you want
to see another clip then you can look at
this clip or this clip either one of
these so did you pick one or he's still
just watching me do this cuz it's
alarming